I feel like a lot of their liquors have
snakes in them hopefully this isn't like
the hangover 2 which was incredibly
disappointing I'm probably gonna throw
up
if not that all I'm gonna like it I'll
probably dislike it
Cheers welcome to tile welcome smells
Christmasy sour weird yeah weird
that's [ __ ] delicious it's nice I
don't even know if it's alcohol I can
drink this on a beach
Howry so you just get people boozed up
as soon as they step off the places that
people like Tyler I know it huh yeah
makes me sing oh he smells like a garage
if he played beer pong in a while it
tastes like freshman year of college
it's pretending I like it a little more
like Miller highlights
whiny Google oh this is like beer pong
beer who cares if we have like little
leaves in it this looks fancy these are
the ones that scare me yeah I'm scared
what is this is it's celery is this an
animal is lemongrass it was like a good
cut through stuff yeah it smells like a
Vegas hotel oh my Lanta great I hate
that Miami yeah this feels like a
vacation a string Spring Break Vegas
what is this again I tightly tie
children putting a big buttons really
nice
that's great that's terrible
oh my honestly just breathe in the drink
like eenie meenie oh my god Oh welcome
to Thailand hi yeah yo Neil what the
[ __ ] is this an accepted part of the
date where your bowl just like hold on
I'm crying no that's gonna be just bed
mmm I'm just connecting the dots the bad
guy in hangover
it's Chang oh maybe hangover too is a
little better than I thought wait wait
nope hangover - wasn't that great
something some kind of like a sweet
little caramel hurts oh man
you know we're fine we're [ __ ] fine
it's like all right you're at your mom's
house hmm
you're gonna go pee she has a little
potpourri dish you accidentally hit it
follow the toilet into your feet and
it's almost like I'll give you five
bucks to drink that all right hopper E&P
Oh trying to find an American beer is
kind of like a Heineken Blue Moon are
like a shock minor Heineken a mine again
this is fun what nothing because we
haven't made anything this bad Thailand
we're not just a party town oh my bundle
just tightened up it's not we for
anything no you take it as a shot come
on sorry guys right
oh sweet click my last like nail polish
remover yeah I didn't really have a
taste to it but I don't know if that's
because like I don't have a tongue is
exactly when you turn 20 and you've
saved up to go over to Thailand I'm just
gonna go over there not remember the
whole goddamn trip but you're gonna come
back and be like I found myself my mom
doesn't know that I drink so she's
heavily disappointed right now well I'm
nice and drunk what a roller coaster of
emotions
huh the one with the chili pepper was my
favorite the one that destroyed you
think it was a good experience dump me I
keep it the pepper I hire Nana you got
me my favorite was the pepper drink
until it turned against me in man
mom
sorry you know what's up and I'm over 21
Wow right you got isn't it though